Rachele crews number one New York Times
bestselling author of the book smart
money smart kids that co-authored the
book with me my daughter is with us for
a couple of segments to talk about this
idea of student loans and you know
Rachel I was thinking by the way the
phone number if you want to get in on
that is triple eight eight two five five
two two five when I started this radio
show twenty five years ago you were a
tiny baby and um the boomer generation
the baby boomers of which I am kind of
in the tail end of it at 55 years old we
were labeled a self-centered and
materialistic and the financial problem
that came with that was credit cards
credit card debt credit card debt was
the crisis of the day
when I went on the air in personal
finance and it was reflected back on
that generation you know people would
say well they're you know they're
self-centered it's all about
materialistic it's all about looking
like something you're not they're not
authentic boomers this boomers that I
was always running the Boomer down in
the rear end you know the result is this
huge credit card debt crisis that we
have so of course I started talking
attacking credit cards right off the bat
going on the air in the early days on
this show and it's interesting to have
watched it you know we went through the
Yuppie generation yuppies were a thing
for a while and we've gone through and
in this student loan crisis now has
become a political football the student
loan discussion the cost of education
has become a political football in the
presidential campaign but it's also kind
of gone back on the Millennial and the
Millennial you know getting $100,000 in
student loan debt on a degree that's not
usable in the marketplace and then
feeling entitled to get it paid off
that's becoming almost stereotypical
with the millennial millennial the
student loan crisis is tied to the
Millennial in that way like the credit
card debt thing was tied sicker
to the baby boomer in a negative way and
you're seeing that a lot working with
Millennials aren't you
yeah that's it's interesting well thanks
for having me back on by the way but
yeah I think you know and I always want
to say when we when we talk about this
there's
sector of Millennials who are doing it
right nobody goes all over and there's
ones that have caught it on the show but
a handful of them the loud one seems
like and the majority of students are
graduating with student loans and I
think that I think it's I think it's
multiple thing something number one I
think there's an ignorance to it because
everyone in their life is telling them
that there's no way they can go to
school without student loans and at this
age they're signing up at 18 years old
for debt now credit cards sure you could
sign up at 18 in your generation but you
guys were or working as adults keeping
up with the Joneses like that was the
big kind of mantra of the credit card
that these 18 your other kids and so
they're really listening to people older
than them and people over know their
parents financial aid officers teachers
and in goodwill these people because
they believes a lie are telling their
this child who's 18 that this is the
only way to go to school so for them
they've accepted this as a true so
there's a little bit of ignorance
because they don't know there's another
way they really don't and then number
two I would say yeah there may be a
sense of of entitlement not with
everyone but this sense of okay well I
deserve to go to a school I deserve to
go to the school that I want to go to
whether that's where my friends are
going where my favorite football team is
just because I got accepted I get to go
there like you know there's a little bit
of that playing in the mix of all of
this and with the degree thing you know
everyone's like oh get a degree in what
you're passionate about so then you meet
students who are going to a school cost
twenty thousand dollars a year and
they're getting a degree in left hand
puppetry right and you're like you can't
use that out in the marketplace and so
it really is it's a mixture of things
that you that really I think make the
perfect storm but I think a big thing
too isn't like at 18 years old they're
signing their financial lives away and
there's not a lot of people in the world
that believe that you can go to school
without debt and there's not those
people speaking into their lives so
that's why I think it's so important
what you're doing on the radio every day
so much of the mission of this place is
to get the word out and so that they
don't have to create this bondage at 18
but they can't have this freedom they
can go through school yes tough it's
hard for years to possibly go to a
community college or school you don't
really want to go to applying for
scholarships and grants keeping your
grades up and working like all these
things combined but it's still possible
lots of people can go to school everyone
could go to school debt-free but no one
talks to them about that idea
and it requires working while you're in
school college choice is by far
mathematically biggest yeah the biggest
issue in the math and because the the if
you sit down and look at what a college
costs versus what another college costs
are university costs versus what another
university cost in-state out-of-state
private private prestige versus
Community College and for the first two
years and get some of your basics out of
the way there are ways to do it if you
decide that's important but the problem
is is that people are taking out student
loans to do that they're taking out
student loans to maintain their
lifestyle while they're in school
they're buying cars with them yet their
rent they're paying their rent with them
and calling them financing my education
into a place to live while I'm going
through education but basically you know
they've got a pile of money here they're
going to use it and and so it just keeps
piling up and piling up and piling up
but it's it's interesting how and I am a
hundred percent sure we've got a five
hundred forty four people on our team a
whole bunch of our Millennials and
they're excellent they're excellent
people and they're excellent team
members so this idea that all
Millennials are entitled spoiled brats
is not true but there are some loudmouth
ones out there who are having a little
temper fit in the cereal aisle because
they don't like their little life and
they made the choices yes yes they were
misled but they made the choices
absolutely and their approach to it is
making some of us who are more
responsible kind of angry at them to say
the least and make fun of them in the
process as well so arm you're not do a
pass just because you woke up one
morning and didn't understand so
interesting stuff u.s. citizens
currently have we've talked about this
over 1.3 trillion it's really about 1.4
trillion in student loan debt and here's
how the bumped up it's just bumping like
windows up every day yeah I know that
but I mean um it's one any question
here's some of the negative results 29%
of student loan borrowers are putting
off marriage 43% of student loan
borrowers delay starting a family
seventy-three percent of student loan
borrowers delay saving for retirement
this is real
oh it's affecting everything it's
affecting the economy it's
it's affecting these these borrowers and
what's so hard is student loan debt for
the most part besides the mortgages the
top the largest debt people have and it
seems like an impossible mountain to
climb
you know there's 40 50 60 thousand
dollars of debt and it's like oh how can
I pay this off and that's the
frustrating thing is that you know they
look in a goal retirement so far away
I'll just pay them own payments on
student loans once I get done with that
then maybe I'll think about retirement
you know it's just this it's the sick
cycle and if you don't break it hard
then yeah it is going to affect your
life hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope
you are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show if
you didn't know I actually have my own
YouTube channel so I had two videos
twice a week on life and money so you
can click the subscribe button to
subscribe to my channel and you want to
check out our video right now check out
the video on how to make a budget